there are new questions about the
structure of that pedestrian bridge that
collapsed in South Florida Thursday
killing at least six people David Beck
know is in Miami where one engineer
noticed cracks in the bridge had been
found days before it collapsed David
good morning Anthony good morning the
lead engineer on this bridge project is
a man named Denny Payton he works for
fij Figg bridge engineering here's what
happened he called to the Florida
Department of Transportation to say
there are cracks in the bridge he seemed
concerned enough to call but said that
there weren't issues from a safety
perspective he called and left a
voicemail on Tuesday the bridge
collapsed Thursday but nobody listened
to that voicemail until Friday here's
the voicemail callin to share with you
some information about the FIU
pedestrian bridge and some cracking
that's been observed on the north end of
the span the pile on end of that span we
moved this weekend so we've taken a look
at it and obviously some repairs or
whatever will have to be done but from a
safety perspective we don't see that
there's any issue there so we're not
concerned about it from that perspective
although obviously the cracking is not
good and something's going to have to be
you know done to repair that despite the
voicemail the Florida Department of
Transportation says at no point did Figg
engineers or the University build team
communicate that there was a life safety
issue the department also said had it
been notified of stress testing it may
have issued a permit for partial or full
road closure if the University asked for
it in a statement released late last
night
Figg bridge engineers said they are
carefully examining the steps that our
team has taken in the interest of our
overarching concern for Public Safety
they also say the latest evaluation did
not indicate safety issues but they are
working to find out what factors led to
this tragic situation meanwhile there is
stunning new dashcam video showing the
950 ton bridge collapsing across eight
lanes of moving traffic on Thursday NTSB
investigators have been trying to figure
out what went wrong
Friday night the NTSB is Robert Squire
addressed reports
cracks in the bridge I would have to say
that a crack in a bridge does not
necessarily mean that it's unsafe I
don't know if that was related to the
cracks that they discovered that's still
too early in the investigation for us to
determine the collapse killed at least
six people including eighteen-year-old
Alexa Durant on Friday crews started to
remove debris but several vehicles are
still pinned this morning after people
saw the bridge crumble some jumped out
of their cars others ran out of their
offices to help the moment that I just
won't ever forget insisting the look on
people's faces medical student Oh Marva
car and dr. Rebecca Martinez were two of
the first first responders on scene one
man kept saying my chest hurts my chest
hurts
the man that was bleeding from the face
kept holding our hand and saying please
don't leave me please don't leave me
officials have been consistent in saying
there are at least six fatalities
leaving the possibility that there could
be even more once they're able to remove
the rubble look the process of getting
these victims out has been agonizingly
slow and that's coming from a man who's
18 year old daughter has been buried in
her car underneath this rubble for
nearly 48 hours Alex
David beg now in Miami with a
heartbreaking story thanks David